is this low-key like a competition yeah
[Music]
to my closets it's not really my closet
I wish it was though so what's gonna go
down today is the P1 Harmony is going to
come into my closet and they're gonna
style me for an entire week not only is
P1 Harmony incredible singers rappers
and dancers they have an aesthetic like
no one it's strong cool fashion forward
but honestly most of the time it's
giving cozy boyfriend Vibes I have no
idea what they're gonna pick but
honestly I don't care because I'm going
to be in a trance the entire time so I'm
a new piece so just say I'm nervous is
an understatement I'm trying not to pass
out maybe we should get them in here
before that happens bring them in baby
nice to meet you hi yeah plus everything
hello we are P1 Harmony hello my name is
up nice to meet you I am Theo nice to
meet you hi guys this is intak hey if
this is you hi my name is Kyo
Welcome to My Closet wow that's
beautiful very cozy I think that we all
have very distinct Styles so I feel like
these six days you'll be like all over
the place but I feel like that'll be fun
I think we'll do a good job of course
I'm confident who do you think will do
the best and who might need a little
help
he's gonna do the worst
laughs each describe your style in three
words I would say rounded I pretty much
wear whatever I want silhouette I like
when the Silhouettes are a little fun I
also like colors
comfortable colors really wide Shake
clean I like black streets
for one sec scar
s
[Music]
so since you're gonna be styling me do
you have any questions for me what are
your favorite color green green is there
like clothes that you find a little
uncomfortable to wear like you don't
like group two revealing stuff or like
two covering stuff I am into more
oversized stuff lately cool I don't
really like wearing heels that much okay
yeah this is good info is this low-key
like a competition yeah
let's do this let's do it let's go
hello my name is up and I choose a
Monday
morning
it's time to dance
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
come on
let me go out my hands going shaking
we will go picnic and I choose the cute
lettering top crop top it's time to
dance yeah it's time to dance fanny pack
and the sunglass the point belt like a
long shirt outside there's very many
mosquito
the little cute earring like a star
pearls
have a good picnic let's have some let's
have fun
good morning happy Monday chose for me
to go on a picnic which is perfect
because I don't have to go to work and B
it's a really nice day outside he just
said natural makeup so I'm going to just
put like a little bit of blush on wait
this is so cute I'm obsessed with this
little picnic outfit listen Chong's home
knew me for like two seconds and he
really did pull a very Lindsay outfit
the denim the color the bucket hat you
know I love my bucket hats you know the
belt is giving very pop star goes to a
picnic and you know what at the end of
the day it's time to dance baby it's
time to dance
it was a beautiful day for a picnic I
met up with Joyce we had yummy food the
Sun was shining the birds were chirping
and then all hell broke loose our picnic
was invaded by bugs everywhere
we had dreams P1 Harmony but the dreams
were destroyed by Nature
[Music]
it's like the opposite of peace Harmony
do I share clothes amongst each other
I don't really steal other people's
clothes but I'm really open with like
letting anyone borrow my stuff but he's
also not he's not a sharer
I think they just don't like when um the
skin is touching like transfer like yeah
like if I'm wearing this my skin touched
this t-shirt he doesn't want to like wow
clean the boys
we love it hi this is June and I chose
Tuesday we're gonna watch a movie let's
go because we're gonna go into the
theater it's dark so I think it should
be a little dark colors
[Music]
[Laughter]
real estate Vibe I don't think we need a
hat because it's gonna uh blind drawer
the screen this war Dr Martin
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
okay I'm done
I made the style for Tuesday and watch a
movie some patterns here some little bag
I picked Gold Jewelry earrings ring and
bracelet necklace kindness
whoa that's the point that's the point
that's the point hair and makeup please
this is it I hope you like it
stay which means I to go to a movie this
outfit is giving fall cozy Vibes and I'm
so excited for okay I am actually losing
my mind because this is so good excuse
me
what have you done this is a look I feel
like the silhouette is just so
flattering on I feel pretty I'm a little
sweaty though but I feel pretty I'm kind
of sad I'm going to a movie to be honest
I feel like more people need to see me
but
I went to the movies with [ __ ] and this
is me showing off my concession skills
because I worked at a movie theater for
two years in high school
look at that technique listen I loved
this look I felt so confident but also
really comfortable we ordered so much
food fantastic choices were made all
around thanks June
where does your style info come from in
my mind yeah we do love shopping like
whenever we have free time I feel like a
lot of us like to go out and shop like
if that's eye shopping or actually
shopping and so once you go to those
stores you see like oh like I guess this
is what people like what's up I'm Kyo
I'm Thursday and we're gonna go shopping
I feel like it has to be comfortable
you're going to be trying stuff on
you're gonna be taking stuff on putting
stuff on so I feel like what you're
wearing to go shopping has to be very
basic yeah right but we don't want to go
boring okay it's basic but fun very easy
but fun oh this expensive stuff in here
[Music]
I think they took all the good jackets
I'm stuck guys I'm stuck
[Laughter]
this looks fun
is this too revealing your belly button
is gonna be out
the inner I feel like needs to be basic
so you can put on stuff and just like
take them off but after the top I think
this would look cool just to have a kind
of a point and shoes there's not a lot
of shoes left I'm gonna go with
something comfortable these white
walkers do you think it's comfortable
have you worn these shoes before
that's what I thought
um and I think these blue earrings would
look good with this blue oh pretty cool
yeah yeah I love it and I don't like
gold guys but I feel like silver you can
never go wrong with silver
whoa no back no no bag yeah you're gonna
be holding so many shopping bags so this
is our Thursday shopping look on top I
wanted to wear something a little more
you know flashy so you don't seem a
little boring because it is white I
wanted to give a little white food so
it's not too dark to match the the
jacket I got these blue earrings and
something just a simple necklace where
it won't clash with the earrings I think
it might so if it does don't wear the
necklace okay take it off it's all good
you can take it off hair I would say
just straighten it and just make it like
just very long and you do have bangs let
the bangs Bang
makeup I think like a just like a soft
I don't know anything about makeup boxer
just like a daily like nothing too crazy
no colors just very nude have a good
shopping trip tell me what you get
Kyo day so last night I got into a trap
of watching Kyo vocal compilations and
that man that man's voice Angelic really
excited for this Look KEO told me to go
shopping which say less the bangs are
banging let the bangs bang oh my God oh
my God I'm obsessed with this color
combo it's very comfortable and cozy and
practical and effortlessly cool I don't
know anything about sports but I feel
very sporty right now I want to go to a
racetrack am I into cars no this is kind
of freaking me out like penguin Harmony
is really good at this I went shopping
with Joys and we had so much fun maybe
too much fun we went to the K-pop store
to get P1 Harmony's album but they were
sold out so congrats he also felt called
to get teddy bears for some reason don't
talk to me and my baby that's my child
so I got this frog I named him Keo
overall I felt so cool in this look so
thanks Kyo
is there a trend or clothing item you
just can't get behind
I probably have to say like leather
pants like no I get it it looks good but
how do you like breathe how do Idols
wear leather pants on stage how do you
dance in it he has actually a really
good tip I mean
[Music]
good so it doesn't stick so it doesn't
stick
me Friday pray okay friends together
let's go yeah
um
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Friday play again
sweeper
game
exercise
two two buns two buns fun play again
goodbye
happy Friday I got my friend's puppy
here
you ready to play video games are you
gonna win
I think I'm about to be transforming
into like an e-girl and I am not ready
for it oh my God who is she listen this
could just be a normal outfit but it's
the space ones and this necklace and the
jewelry that just give me about to join
a twitch stream I love the edginess
paired with the softness also this whole
thing is just extremely comfortable like
what's your gaming Vibe what do you
think you're playing with Call of Duty I
don't know not Call of Duty
playing video games on a Friday evening
is honestly an ideal activity for me so
I am really glad Seoul chose this
I did have someone but essentially I
lost
I won I think what I liked most about
this look is that it was really
practical but it also looked really cool
is there a concept you want to try for a
future come back
always I want to try dude
jacket yeah I think like a cowboy
concert
I do have some boots back there I know I
did see it
hi guys this is in talk I choose
Saturday we're gonna go to a restaurant
eat some dinner let's go okay
[Music]
um
I don't really like wearing heels that
much reviews
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
happy Saturday which means I gotta go
get steak
and pop chose this outfit so quickly
who's probably the swiftest but it's so
badass magician I don't know oh my God
the way that he just paired these
textures so effortlessly and talk
Straight A's all across the board I'm
feeling like this is my Alter Ego
Lisette Lisette rides a Harley she
doesn't need a man I need a motorcycle
right now
intoxic
so weeded steak met up with fellow peace
Becky and we ate the most delightful
meal this is the part where I ascended
into meat Heaven I would conclude that I
looked and smelled Smokey that was a bad
pun sorry
what advice might you have for your fans
that might be struggling with their
confidence I want them to
like remind the ward your one and only
the universe is so large and we're like
this like small of like the dust of a
particle in the space who cares like
just do what you want like I feel like
life is too short to worry about what
other people think I love that
Young
[Music]
man
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Singapore foreign
[Music]
good morning
raining outside and I would be concerned
except tail chose things that are super
cozy it's almost like he knew you know I
feel so cute I actually can't handle how
much I love this outfit you've done
everything that you said you would I
have the giant shoes so that you guys
can see me from the stage also their
light stick is high quality I'm just
genuinely so excited to see the boys
perform just please don't get a cold
today Mama Lindsay said so
I couldn't film inside the concert but
trust me they were so good live their
energy on stage was contagious and I
danced a lot
not only are these boys genuinely so
kind and wonderful people they're such
good stylists I feel so lucky to have
met them thank you guys thank you so
much for having us you have amazing
folks
we actually have a new album a new song
called back down that's out right now
we show a lot of love we hope all our
pieces enjoy it thank you so much for
watching
P1 Harmony thank you
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]